wisst ihr was das hier ist das sind
amerikanische globuli und warum zeige
ich euch die weil die hier besser sind
als deutsche globuli aber als auch mal
feiern den letzten wochen in den usa und
dabei ist mir etwas ziemlich
interessantes aufgefallen wie ihr
vielleicht wisst gibt es in den usa
keine apotheken wie in deutschland
sondern pharmacy es sind drogeriemarkt
und apotheken ein also da wo man sich
sein shampoo kaufhof man sich auch seine
herzmedikamente es gibt eine theke für
rezeptpflichtige medikamente aber alle
nicht rezeptpflichtigen medikamente für
die man in deutschland aber trotzdem zur
apotheke muss zb schmerzmittel oder
sachen gegen erkältung und so weiter die
stehen einfach wie shampoo im regal und
man kann sich einfach bedienen so jetzt
kommt das spannende ich dachte ich
schaue einfach mal so aus neugier nach
homöopathischen mitteln ganz vereinzelt
habe ich im regal zwischen den normalen
medikamenten auch homöopathische mittel
entdeckt dass hier das hier aber es gab
jetzt keine extra abteilung in den
pharmacy und auch keine globuli zum
beispiel erst in dieser alternativen
pharmacy notwendig und dann später auch
noch in einem alternativen supermarkt
aber das eigentlich interessante ist was
auf diesen homöopathischen mitteln
draufsteht claim space und digital home
i perfekt praxis nord accepted medical
evidenz also für die wirksamkeit gibt es
keine akzeptierten medizinischen belege
und nord fdlr ea das heißt die
offizielle behörde die food and drug
administration hat dieses mittel nicht
geprüft und das ist nun mal so über
homöopathie es gibt eben für
homöopathische mittel tatsächlich keine
akzeptierten medizinischen belege
deswegen ist es erstmal nicht verwundern
nicht dass dieser das klima hier drauf
stehen muss aber bei uns in deutschland
ist das ganz anders
da ich habe ja dass hier mitbekommen
juli anbieter liefert pharmafirma geht
juristisch gegen homöopathie kritiker
vor der geht es unter anderem um diese
aussage dass das der europa-chef des
mitteleuropäischen mittelfeld bisher
grundsätzlich bei allen mitteln die
homöopathisch daherkommen einen
wirksamkeitsnachweis dieser
wissenschaftler bekam von der deutschen
homöopathie firma hevert eine abmahnung
für diese aussage denn
diese aussage sei falsch und wenn er sie
wiederholt soll er dafür jedes mal eine
hohe geldstrafe zahlen
selbe firma produziert aber auch für den
amerikanischen markt und da steht
wiederum der uns inzwischen bekannte
disclaimer drauf wie kann es sein dass
eine firma in deutschland eine abmahnung
verteilen dafür eine aussage die sie in
den usa auf ihre verpackung schreiben
müssen die antwort lautet innen konsens
und hinter diesem langen bei nichtleben
dem wort steckt eine unglaubliche
geschichte deswegen freunde der sonne
setzt euch macht es euch gemütlich hole
durch ein t hier steigen jetzt ein in
die welt des deutschen
arzneimittelgesetzes und die werden
nicht glauben wie verrückt es gleich
wird es gab eine zeit da war es in
deutschland relativ einfach neues
medikament auf den markt zu bringen
der hersteller musste und dass dafür nur
bei dem damaligen bundesgesundheitsamt
registrieren
registrierungen klingt vielleicht
offiziell aber so eine registrierung
erfordert keinen nachweis über die
wirkungen oder nebenwirkungen ob oder
wie es wirkt oder ob die nebenwirkung
vielleicht viel zu stark waren das
konnten sich die hersteller quasi selbst
überlegen regelt ja der markt könnte man
argumentieren so kam es dass
unzureichend getestete medikamente sehr
schlimme nebenwirkungen hervorrufen da
sind wirklich furchtbare sachen
vorgefallen
rund 5000 kinder
kommen mit missbildungen zur welt das
schlafmittel contergan steht im verdacht
die ursache zu sein
deswegen musste sich etwas ändern in den
70ern wurde eine arzneimittel reform
verabschiedet jetzt mussten die
hersteller ihre medikamente auf
sicherheit testen und diese test
vorlegen außerdem gab es noch eine
revolutionäre neuerung medikamente
dürften jetzt nur auf den markt werden
sie auch wirkten krass oder etwas so was
scheinbar selbstverständlich ist das
medikament auch wird muss ist erst seit
ein paar jahrzehnten geregelt und
manchen ist vielleicht gar nicht klar
wie wichtig die wirksamkeit ist also man
könnte ja sagen solange das ding keine
nebenwirkungen hat schadet es ja auch
niemandem wenn ich jetzt statt eines
wirksamen medikamenten und wirksames
medikament kaufen dann hab ich im
harmlosesten fall einfach nur geld
rausgeschmissen aber vermutlich werde
ich auch noch unnötig lange unter meiner
krankheit leiden zum beispiel eine
schmerzende mittelohrentzündung und ein
wirksames medikament ist ja auch nicht
als unterlage eventuelle komplikationen
zu verhindern wie zum beispiel eine
entzündung des innenohrs die dann auch
bleibende schäden hinterlässt und wenn
nicht eine wirklich ernsthafte krankheit
habe und dann meine zeit mit
irgendwelchem unwirksam und quatsch
verschwende anstatt eine echte therapie
anzufangen
dann kann das im zweifel mein leben
kosten wie zum beispiel bei dieser
18-jährigen sie bekamen einen bösartigen
knochenkrebs verhandelt wurde sie mit
geistheilung und homöopathie keinen
wirksamen medikamente noch nicht einmal
schmerzmittel und dieser krebs ist sehr
schmerzhaft drei jahre später starb sie
abgemagert und mit metastasen in libanon
eine konventionelle behandlung kann
diesen krebsarten mit einem über 70
prozentigen wahrscheinlichkeit heilen
und hätte dieser junge frau zumindest
schlimme qualen erspart also unwirksamer
mitchells medikamente zu verkaufen kann
verdammt gefährlich sein und diese
gefahr sahen auch die politiker damals
durch die anwendung eines unwegsamen
arzneimittel kann nämlich dem patienten
ein wirksames arzneimittel vorenthalten
und damit eine heilung verschleppt und
unmöglich werden ihre informelle
registrierung sollte ersetzt werden
durch die zulassung für eine zulassung
ist folgendes gefordert
da vom pharmazeutischen unternehmer
zukünftig nur dann in verkehr gebracht
werden
denn diese die erforderliche qualität
wirksamkeit und unbedenklichkeit des
arzneimittels nachgewiesen hat und zwar
wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen versteht
sich so super reform oder das fand nicht
jeder ein besonderer widerstand
zahlreiche anhänger der besonderen
therapierichtungen haben schwerwiegende
bedenken gegen die vorgesehene
zulassungsregeln geltend gemacht und dem
staat grundsätzlich das recht bestritten
durch ein präventives
zulassungsverfahren den marktzugang
eines arzneimittels zu kontrollieren mit
besonderen therapierichtungen sind hier
drei alternativ medizin richtungen
gemeint nämlich die homöopathie die
anthroposophische medizin und die
pflanzenheilkunde die drei sind
wohlgemerkt sehr verschieden die
pflanzenheilkunde ist vom grundgedanken
euch genauso wie die pharmakologie aus
in pflanzen sind substanz enthalten die
eine wirkung haben in der homöopathie
kommen keine klassischen wirkstoff wird
zum einsatz sondern substanzen die nicht
gegen diese symptome wirken sondern die
ähnliche symptome wie die krankheit
auslösen gleiches mit gleichem bekämpfen
oder ähnliches mit ähnlichem bekämpfen
ist das prinzip der zupackt da noch
diese seltsame sache dass homöopathen
die substanzen daran auch so auch für
dünnen das in den meisten fällen am ende
gar nichts mehr übrig bleibt das wirken
kann schaut euch bei gelegenheit einfach
mal dieses video an dass ich bald rx der
show gemacht habe wenn ihr mehr wissen
wollt zur wirkung oder nicht wirkung von
homöopathie
die anthroposophische medizin die
verordnung einen ganz anderen ansatz
aber das bringt jetzt den rahmen hier in
diese drei therapierichtungen die
besonderen therapierichtungen hatten
damals eine einflussreiche lobby um die
tat alles dafür um sich für diesen
wirksamkeitsnachweis zu drücken und die
begründungen waren damals dieselben wie
heute zwei der wichtigsten argumente
erstens unsere heilkunst ist einfach zu
individuell ein klassisches
homöopathisches präparat wie zum
beispiel diese globuli rolle ich einfach
gegen schnupfen helfen sondern das ist
viel individueller ist das ein zum
beispiel eine verstopfte nase mit
schläfrigkeit am nachmittag prickeln im
rücken und dem träumen von früheren
ereignissen zusammenkommt dann passt
aconitum der paulus wenn er über die
verstopfte nase mit schläfrigkeit am
morgen jugend im auge und träumen von
gewitter zusammen kommt braucht ein ganz
anderes präparat nämlich auf raser auch
vize nahles und genau deswegen sagen die
homöopathen das ist alles so individuell
das kann man überhaupt nicht in einer
wissenschaftlichen studie nachweisen
dass natürlich nicht sehr überzeugend
werden ihn von präparat helfen soll
gegen schnupfen plus xyz da muss man es
halt test und mit einer gruppe von
patienten die schnupfen rahmen plus xyz
genau das macht man nämlich auch bei der
personalisierten medizin zum beispiel
bei der modernen personalisierten
krebstherapie
mal abgesehen davon es gibt ja neben den
globuli auch sogenannte homöopathische
komplexe beraten
das sind dann die sachen die so aussehen
wie normale medizin und diese komplex
präparate haben angeblich ganz
individuelle wirkung wie zum beispiel
gegen schnupfen oder gegen erkältungen
sage meinen das zweite beliebte argument
mit dem sich die besonderen
therapierichtungen davor drücken ihre
wirkungen auch nachweisen zu müssen ist
die entscheidungsfreiheit der bürger der
staat darf mir doch nicht vorschreiben
wie ich meine krankheit behandelt
darüber kann man mal gegen streiten aber
das argument geht hier am thema vorbei
denn homöopathika sollten nicht verboten
werden
es war angedacht homöopathische mittel
und er das lebensmittelrecht zu packen
das heißt dass die so verkauft werden
dürfen wie nahrungsergänzungsmittel
ob das jetzt die beste lösung ist
darüber kann man sich auch streiten aber
die homöopathie anhänger hätten sich auf
jeden fall weiter versorgen können also
die entscheidungsfreiheit der bürger war
sicherlich nicht gefährdet und trotzdem
hatte die alternativmedizin lobby damals
erfolg denn sie erkämpfte sich ein paar
sehr wichtige gesetzliche ausnahmen bei
der arzneimittel reform die noch heute
gelten extrawürste für die homöopathie
extrawurst einst homöopathische mittel
brauchen keine zulassung diese globuli
zum beispiel müssen lediglich
registriert werden und das obwohl ihr
eigentlich mit der arzneimittel reform
die registrierung abgeschafft werden
sollte
dafür wird vom amt geprüft ob das mittel
nach der traditionellen homöopathischen
lehre hergestellt wurde
3 und dass das mittel nicht etwa giftig
ist immerhin das ist jetzt bei diesen
globuli schnell abgehakt das aus hat so
gar nicht viel drin beziehungsweise nur
mengen die so gering sind dass sie
völlig haltlos sind es gibt allerdings
homöopathika die nur schwach verdünnt
sind also durchaus noch giftige
substanzen drin sein können also die
sind dann insofern nicht traditionellen
als dass sie nicht zu stark runter wird
uns sind aber die werden trotzdem als
homöopathika verkauft also homöopathie
heißt nicht automatisch ungiftig bei
registrierten präparaten steht da drauf
registriertes homöopathisches
arzneimittel daher ohne angabe einer
therapeutischen indikationen spricht
hier dürfen nicht sagen wofür oder
wogegen das gut sein soll
aber es gibt auch homöopathische mittel
butt draufsteht wogegen das wirkt
medizin zum beispiel eines der
beliebtesten homöopathischen mittel hier
kommen wir zu extrawurst 2
homöopathische mittel können auch
zugelassen werden müssten aber nicht
dieselben standards erfüllen wie
medikamente ok jetzt kommt der knaller
medizin sie zum beispiel ist ein
zugelassenes homöopathisches mittel um
zulassung bedeutet ja dass man die
wirksamkeit nachgewiesen hat aber jetzt
haltet euch fest wie
wirksamkeitsnachweis durch punkte
sammeln im gegensatz zu medikamenten
deren wirksamkeitsnachweis sich auf
wissenschaftliche studien stützen muss
gelten für homöopathische mittel ganz
andere standards werden punkte vergeben
für verschiedenes ecke nistmaterial hier
ist eine tabelle die zeigt wie viele
erkenntnis punkte für eine zulassung von
homöopathischen mittel nötig ist als
wirksamkeitsnachweis für die besserung
der symptome einer leichten krankheit
reichen zwei punkte zur unterstützenden
behandlung einer schweren krankheit
reichen vier punkte schauen wir mal für
diese punkte vergeben werden einen punkt
gibt es zum beispiel dafür dass die
zuständige expertenkommission bestätigt
dass die wirkung der homöopathischen
lehre entspricht oder dafür dass andere
homöopathie experten
zu diesem schluss gekommen sind gleich
zwei punkte gibt es für eine
homöopathische arzneimittel prüfung
klingt zwar wissenschaftlich ist es aber
nicht auf so eine homöopathische
arzneimittelprüfung läuft folgendermaßen
ab laut der homöopathischen lehre lösen
homöopathische mittel bei gesunden
menschen symptome aus die den symptomen
einer krankheit ähneln um herauszufinden
welche das sind werden globuli an
gesunde verabreicht und die schreiben
dann wochen ein haar klein auf was sie
so alles an sich feststellen können
rechte augenbraue
all das gilt dann als offizielle
symptome gegen die dann dieses
arzneimittel hilft und das führt dann
eben dazu dass zum beispiel aconitum bei
verstopfter nase schläfrigkeit am
nachmittag kribbeln im rücken und
träumen von früher in hessen was euch
gefragt hat wie man auf so was kommt und
abgesehen von diesen ohnehin fragwürdige
methoden ist noch nicht mal eine
verblendung oder eine kontrolle für
placebo effekte erforderlich also noch
mal zwei punkte gibt es für diese völlig
unwissenschaftlich arzneimittelprüfung
bei der zulassung und so geht sie auf
alltag einer dieser punkte tier und in
der tabelle aufgeführt sind reicht
annähernd für einen wissenschaftlichen
nachweis von wirksamkeit aber alleine so
kann man bereits acht erkenntnis punkte
zu sammeln und über acht punkte benötigt
ein hersteller erst wenn er ein mittel
zur direkten behandlung von schweren
oder lebensbedrohlichen krankheiten
verkaufen
erst dann fordert die kommission einen
wirksamkeitsnachweis im eigentlichen
sinn im wissenschaftlichen sinne und es
wird euch nicht wundern dass bisher kein
einziges homöopathisches präparat in
deutschland so einen nachweis geschafft
hat da fragt man sich doch wer dieses
bescheuerte punktesystem überhaupt
festgelegt hat es war die zuständige
expertenkommission für die
homöopathische therapie richtung hört
selbst und die experten für homöopathie
sind natürlich homöopathen anders gesagt
alles bis zu acht erkenntnis punkten
sagt nichts weiter aus als ja die
homöopathen glauben daran
jetzt kommt der richtige begriff der
schon am anfang viel einen konsens
homöopathische präparate brauchen also
keine aussagekräftigen
wissenschaftlichen studien sondern es
reicht dass sich homöopathen einig sind
dass es wirkt diese regelung nennt sich
binnen konsens also in der konsens
innerhalb der homöopathischen community
herrscht einigkeit
das ist jetzt für laien echt tricky denn
beim klimawandel spricht man ja auch
ständig von konsens und sich die
wissenschaftler einig sind wo es also
der unterschied was viele nicht wissen
oder was viele missverstehen ist beim
wissenschaftlichen konsens geht es
keinesfalls um eine demokratische
abstimmung zwischen wissenschaftlern
oder um eine übereinstimmung von
meinungen sondern es geht beim
wissenschaftlichen konsens einzig und
allein um die übereinstimmung der
wissenschaftlichen daten
wissenschaftliche daten wirklich
wissenschaftliche daten gibt es bei der
zulassung nach binnenkonsums nicht und
damit kommen wir zum eigentlichen witz
wissenschaftlich unwirksam
rechtlich wirksam vor dem gesetz vor dem
deutschen gesetz ist mit dem binnen
konsens die wirksamkeit nachgewiesen
also nicht wissenschaftlich aber rein
rechtlich das geht sogar so weit dass
die firma kloster kennt ihr bestimmt
einmal vor gericht war weil sie wollte
dass ein produkt von ihnen nicht als
pathologisches arzneimittel eingestuft
wird weil es auch überhaupt nichts
pankow logisch wirksam war aber es
enthielt eine homöopathische substanz
die entsprechend potenziert also
verdünnt war und deswegen kam sie nicht
damit durch doch eigentlich unwegsame
homöopathika vom gesetzgeber als
arzneimittel eingestuft wurden halten
sie eine pharmakologische wirkung quasi
dank gesetzeskraft er strickt der
gesetzgeber den arzneimittel begriff auf
diese präparate so ist doch der begriff
der pharmakologischen wirkung in
rechtlicher hinsicht auf diese zu
erstrecken
die immer noch verrückt kommen wir
zurück zum teil mit der abmahnung beim
japanischen mittelfeld bisher
grundsätzlich bei allen mitteln die
homöopathisch daherkommen einen
wirksamkeitsnachweis und wolle damit
völlig recht hat argumentiert die
mahnende homöopathie firma
folgendermaßen die wirksamkeit der
arzneimittel für diese anwendungsgebiete
wurde gegenüber dem bundesinstitut für
arzneimittel und medizinprodukte
wissenschaftlich nachgewiesen noch mal
wissenschaftlich wurde gar nichts
nachgewiesen aber ein sogenannter
wirksamkeitsnachweis besteht vor dem
gesetz dann binnen konsens was nun
wir müssen uns einig sein ob ein
medikament wirkt oder nicht darf nicht
durch irgendein amt einfach geschlossen
werden sondern dafür müssen saubere
wissenschaftliche tests durchgeführt
werden
vor allem aber da hat es nicht sein dass
jemand akkurat über den stand der
wissenschaft berichtet und dafür
abgemahnt wird vor allem hat ja nicht
jeder die zeit und das geld für den
rechtsstreit wir sind ja nicht alle jan
böhmermann also liebes
bundesgesundheitsministerium es gibt da
ein gesetz das sie dringend mal
überarbeiten müsst und freunde der sonne
wieder machen jetzt freundes wir gehen
jetzt mal alle in uns wie horch mal in
uns hinein und schreiten alle symptome
auf also wirklich alle nichts vergessen
das gehört alles dazu die gerade
vorgehen weiß nicht rubbeln der bauch
oder wie habt ihr geschlafen was hat er
geträumt dann erstellen wir mal
gemeinsam ein freunde der sonne
arzneimittel bild
[Musik]
frustration gefühle